blue prism is a global leader in
intelligent enterprise automation
transforming the way employees work
by making it simple for individuals to
automate operations
blue prism helps enterprises improve
operational efficiency
and agility hey everyone i welcome you
all to this video
in this video we will understand what is
blue prism let's look at today's agenda
we shall begin with what is blue prism
and see the different features of blue
prism
followed by which we will look at the
architecture of blue prism
and different components of blue prism
proceeding further
we will see the key benefits of flow
prism and some of the real-time
applications of blue prism
finally we will see the companies using
blue prism
and salary trends but before we begin
make sure you have subscribed to our
youtube channel and clicked on the bell
icon
so you never miss an update from
simplylearn so without wasting any
further time
let's get started with blueprism
what is blue prism
blue prism is a software that develops
enterprise robotic process automation
allowing businesses to automate complex
end-to-end operations
blue prism developed the virtual
workforce platform concept
and works on an enterprise robotic
process automation platform
that is strong highly scalable secure
and reliable
blue prism software complements standard
i.t solutions
by utilizing an agile virtual workforce
that follows rule-based business
processes and interacts with the system
in the same way that users do
blueprism's rpa software solution
automates tasks
that would otherwise be carried out
manually by humans or through major
customization of current i.t
systems resulting in a higher level of
automation
with significantly lesser investment and
faster deployment
features of blue prism
intelligent execution technology
organizations can instruct the
autonomous engine
on process priorities feed amounts of
work
and leave it to run without human
involvement responding to systems
business scenarios and change in
priorities
robots like humans can be used to do
tasks based on sla
volume and priority as well as adjust
and change robot allocation dynamically
without human intervention
high security a software robot securely
locks into an application
and manipulates the presentation layer
in the same manner as a person would
but in a controlled non-invasive
environment
ensuring that the application's
integrity is never affected
on premises or in the cloud on-premises
or hybrid enterprise deployment
provisioned in a public or private cloud
the robots are existing and running any
operation
set in blue prism can be conducted on
any number of robots in the virtual
workforce
built on microsoft sql server blueprism
is built on microsoft.net framework
it is technology flexible working across
different platforms
and technologies such as mainframe
windows app
wpf app java sap custom apps
citrix thick client thin client web
services
and so on scalability
blue prism is object oriented allowing
for rapid scalability by utilizing
reusable items and libraries
analytics and reporting blueprism
provides
high quality data that can be used to
produce relevant
bi and mi reporting as well as providing
in-line process
statistics and real-time operational
insights
by capturing each step
work queues work use provides a
cue-centric approach
for dynamically controlling the number
of resources or robots
operating against a given queue at any
given time
allowing for the greatest flexibility in
the adjusting the number of resources
assigned to collaborately work items
architecture of blue prism
blueprism technology is backed by a
comprehensive methodology for rapid
business process development
deployment and operational support
allowing for a whole business process
cycle to be completed within the same
environment
this diagram depicts the architectural
components of blue prism deployment
including all aspects to enable
governance security
and control as well as the inherent
flexibility to support operational
agility and self-service
monitoring and referrals technically
service monitoring and business-owned
referral management for work items
requiring additional
manual steps operational and
methodologies
a comprehensive framework for
implementing blue prism methodologies
including analysis design development
and implementation
i.t governance the principles that
underpin
best practice in the process selection
change management
and release procedures operational
configuration
ownership of blueprism product for
operational configuration
testing and execution
roles and responsibilities within the
methodology there are clear
developed roles for managing and
implementing the many aspects of ongoing
agility security functions of security
products
infrastructure and methodology that
provides secure and
compliant implementation
support and hosting a robust scalable
infrastructure
that allows for rapid deployment and
expansion based on business requirements
components of blue prism
object studio object studio allows
business
users or i.t professionals to construct
reusable blue prism
objects as the building blocks for the
business process
by modeling current applications and
training blue prism as a robotic user
object studio is the design canvas on
which the blue prism robot is programmed
to conduct the fundamental system
activities that serve as the foundation
of process
the presentation layer which provides a
library of elements
with which to operate quickly models and
validates the target desktop application
process studio process studio
provides a similar interface to object
studio and allows you to sequence and
test business logic
control loops variables and object calls
in a visible business flow
process studio allows the company or it
to design
build edit and test processes made out
of reusable blue prism elements
as the library of business object grows
actions can be scheduled and controlled
in the process layer
the top tier of the blue prism
architecture
process in blue prism are comparable to
software procedures
in that they can invoke objects and
operations in order to run applications
automate rule-based process and business
logic
control room control room allows
business or iit services to schedule
perform and control processes blue prism
platform
administrators can use the blue prism
control room interface
to monitor and review the status of
interconnected runtime resources
in the production environment the
interface also allows for manual process
start and stop automated process
schedule setting
and extensive management information and
dig downs into blue prism task queues
applications of blue prism
blue prisms rps software is used in the
following process types
rule-based processing using digital
structured inputs
such as credit card activation or fraud
detection
transactional processing that is
repeated such as
sim swaps or invoice processing
transaction quantities that are high
such as
billing or new handset order processing
issues with process adherence quality
such as policy renewals
or policy migrations
complex mission critical procedures such
as pension redemptions
and financial reconciliation
changes in demand or backlogs such as
new product launches
it is used in hr onboarding or the
introduction
of new online product where no
integration exists
benefits of blue prism
the first benefit is automation speed
days and weeks to automate processes in
blue prism
that would take months and years to
automate using the standard automation
methodologies
less expense robots are programmed with
the business rules of repetitive
duties and deployed to drive existing
applications
eliminating the requirement for costly
integration and process redesign
expertise
improved performance a small specialist
ability
within the iit department collaborates
with the robotic workforce
to train them manage referrals and
continuously enhance the robot's
operational performance
secure the robotic automation platform
is secure
audited and governed with a governance
i.t corridor
the usage of software robots invariably
increases
compliance with applicable data
standards confidentiality
and the speed and accuracy of record
keeping
scalable because the software robots
operate in a virtualized environment
they can be rapidly scaled up and down
based on the demand
companies using blue prism
google microsoft ibm
ey kpmg
accenture siemens and jaguar
salary trends
in india the average salary for a rpa
developer
blue prism is 6 lakhs 4046 rupees per
year
and the salary ranges from five black
1028 rupees
to nine lakhs ninety thousand rupees
in united states the average salary for
a blue prism developer
is eighty eight thousand eight hundred
and seventy five dollars
and the salary ranges from sixty
thousand three sixty two dollars
to one thirty thousand eight hundred and
fifty seven dollars
so with that we have reached the end of
this video
please like and share if you found it
interesting
thank you for being here keep learning
and stay tuned to simply loves
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here